[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du 7-8 culture et tout de
suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 2 mai
10 ans de travail pour se plonger dans
l'histoire du jansénisme à port royal
des champs philippe lui et le directeur
du musée signe un ouvrage événements les
deux thèmes n'avait pas encore été
traitée ensemble de la farine comme
modèle ou presque le photographe de
fontenay le fleury art nos shoots
propose des clichés un peu particulier
est l'une de nos journalistes s'est fait
tirer le portrait à montigny le
bretonneux on poursuit les moments à
vivre en famille avec un spectacle on
suit trois villandry ngo qui dévalisent
chaque soir les voyageurs et une nuits
dans le carrosse attaqués se trouvent
nos folies une rencontre qui va changer
les malfrats deux histoires qui
s'entremêlent pour parfois ce qu'on peut
se confondre port royal des champs et le
jansénisme alors ce sont deux histoires
qui ont aussi passionné un homme
philippe lui et le directeur du musée
situé à magny les hameaux et une passion
qui vous a mené à un livre on soit
danseur il dit alors vous avez publié
aux éditions belin port royal et le
jansénisme des religieuses face à
l'absolutisme
c'est un ouvrage les dents besoin il n'y
en avait pas et n'ont curieusement y en
avait pas alors que sur port royal en
inde et km2 de livres sur les rayons des
bibliothèques notamment celle du musée
mais ce sujet là n'existait pas
n'étaient pas traités un vrai manque
comme moi je suis venue pour la première
fois comme visiteurs au musée je les
cherche et librairies c'était j'étais
étudiant j'ai dit doit y avoir un livre
sur aurillac et le jansénisme qui était
un sujet que je suis j'étais en train
d'étudier à la fac d'histoire rien j'en
fais un côté port royal mais jamais
vraiment les deux se confondent vie je
dirais
ia jansénisme il ya rarement port royal
et en même temps les livres sur le
jansénisme mêle l'histoire de porc au
rial et l'histoire du jansénisme alors
il y a eu un livre sur l'abbaye de port
royal donc celle de l'abbaye deschamps
celle qui est sur le territoire de saint
quentin qui avaient été publiés dans les
années 20 par cécile gazier et c'est
peut-être le seul exemple d'un livre qui
est traité de l'histoire de ce lieu
mais sinon pour le reste du sujet c'est
plutôt une grande histoire générale qui
pose une question un moment
voilà un moment particulier qui est ce
moment du jansénisme c'est un abominable
gros mots le jansénisme cesson ça
renvoie à des souvenirs que nous avons
pour les plus âgés d'entre nous c'est
les années bac français
c'est l'étude de pascal c'est quelque
chose auquel on comprend rien moi le
premier je n'avais rien compris et c'est
sur cette idée là que finalement on a
gardé jusqu'à aujourd'hui le souvenir de
ce mystérieux port royal qui serait le
cadre de cette non moins mystérieuse
chose qu'est le jansénisme et que ces
dons ce cadre là que le génie de pascal
a donné un des textes les plus
importantes de la littérature européenne
alors je les ai dans les titres vous
avez fait presque dix ans de travail
pour sortir cet ouvrage pourquoi dix ans
et elle semble temps de tout rassembler
de confronter des écrits oui en même
temps il ya à la fois une véritable
envie c'est à dire en arrivant au musée
ce sentiment que c'était dans le rôle du
musée de pouvoir un jour produire un
ouvrage qui soit un ouvrage de référence
sur l'histoire du lieu
et pourquoi ce lieu et si est intimement
mêlés à ces questions du jansénisme
c'était la première chose et puis je
crois une question d'opportunité
l'opportunité c'était qu'un éditeur et
un éditeur aussi important que les
éditions belin 10 ce sujet m'intéresse
il a vraiment un sens pour la collection
histoire qui que cet éditeur publie qui
est à la fois une collection qui
traitent de sujets un niveau
universitaire mais qui a cette ambition
de pouvoir être
lui par le grand public or saint c'est
le coeur et l'ajustement du pont royal
et le jansénisme c'est une histoire
importante parce que ça débute vers
odyssée au début du xviie siècle sauf
erreur de ma part oui en quoi cet
important les généralistes à port royal
c'est absolument capital peut-être parce
que c'est un moment clé charnière de
notre histoire en france de notre
histoire politique pour faire très très
vite c'est à la fois d'un point de vue
des individus la première fois que l'on
pose de manière aussi claire la question
de la liberté individuelle à travers un
choix religieux mais très largement la
question individuelle s'étend au xviiie
siècle ensuite sur la liberté de
conscience tout court donc un des axes
fondateurs de notre de notre culture
l'autre question c'est que ces mêmes
gens de port royal à travers le
jansénisme pose la question non plus de
l'indépendance de l'individu mais du
rôle de la politique et de l'autonomie
de la politique par rapport notamment à
la conscience et par rapport à la
religion donc c'est la première fois que
tout d'un coup on dit la gestion
politique de la france n'est pas ne doit
pas être tous pas être liée avec la
gestion religieuse donc c'est un autre
élément clé je crois de notre histoire
tout découle le pouvoir se laïcise entre
guillemets c'est à dire se défait de ce
qui l'a été jusqu'à maintenant c'est à
dire le la dimension religieuse et
vantant le directeur ce qu'il en est le
directeur depuis 2005
est ce que ça a changé votre regard vous
avez découvert des choses que vous ne
connaissiez pas oui oui sinon c'était
aussi le l'intérêt d'un livre comme
celui là est précisément sur un sujet
qui apparemment est énormément traité la
première chose c'est m apercevoir que
d'abord il sort de pau rial comme lieu
on la connaît on l'appelle c'est très
mal donc c'était intéressant de voir
comment ça s'était passé au xviie siècle
comment les jo y avait vécu
l'autre chose c'est est que à trop
penser la question théologique qui est
très compliqué et que même les gens du
17e ne comprenait probablement pas
on oubliait finalement d'autres
questions beaucoup plus importante qui
était que les gens qui sont venus vivre
à l'abbaye et autour de l'abbaye dans le
petit village de mesnil et sa requête
aujourd'hui magny-les-hameaux avait une
démarche qui était une démarche
complètement conforme à ce qui se
passait au xviie siècle
c'est à dire dans cette émergence de la
conscience individuelle
cette idée que l'on pouvait socialement
faire un choix
ce choix était je renonce aux honneurs
et je me retire
je me retire à la campagne je me retire
en marge d'un monastère donc finalement
voir que faire l'histoire de port royal
c'est faire un petit peu une sorte de
micro étude sur comment une partie de
l'aristocratie française a pu choisir
à un moment donné de s'émanciper du roi
peut-être parfois de l'église pour
choisir un mode de vie un petit peu
particulier
et ça s'est relativement non merci fait
les plus basses que le temps court
je voulais pour contaminer cet entretien
de faire un petit retour sur l'actualité
plus récentes sur mont-royal des chances
a été annoncé par nos confrères du
canard enchaîné le 21 février dernier la
mairie pour être attaché au domaine du
château de versailles est ce que ça
avançait ce que vous en savez un peu
plus je n'ose je ne sais pas plus la
question en fait et moins la question du
rattachement de port royal ou à
l'établissement public de versailles qui
est une hypothèse de travail qui a été
proposé dans un document
publié vers novembre vers novembre
dernier c'est une hypothèse je crois il
faut pas s'arrêter en fait à 7 à cet
aspect de la question le fond de la
question et une forme de rationalisation
de la gestion des établissements du
ministère de la culture et dans cette
réflexion qui est actuellement en cours
au ministère il y a plusieurs
possibilités pour voir comment le musée
pourrait être mieux administrée en tout
cas et pour le public qui vient et qui
connaît pour royal ça ne changera rien
c'est simplement il rationaliser et à
férel lorsqu on en saura plus lorsque
les choix seront faits merci philippe
lui est alors un rappel pour votre
ouvrage ce port royal et le jansénisme
des religieuses face à l'absolutisme et
les publier aux éditions belin de la
peinture de la photographie et de la
sculpture depuis le 30 avril le carré à
la farine à versailles accueille
quatorze artistes amateurs mais
passionnés ils partagent leur art
jusqu'au 13 mai reportage réalisé avec
marion tac
[Musique]
à travers de petites touches d'acrylique
muriel gars sont un des paysages
cette chaîne et viennent à commencer par
le dessin avant de prendre le pinceau
la peinture c'est quelque chose où
j'essaie de retransmettre des ambiances
j'aime beaucoup voyagé donc ça c'est une
de mes passions donc souvent c'est des
impressions de voyage des couleurs qui
représente la magie des paysages que je
vois
comme muriel très autres artistes
exposent au carré à la farine
un collectif d'amateurs avertis qui se
prépare depuis trois ans
chacun est libre d'y exposer ce qui lui
plaît en fait je laisse toujours les
artistes aussi bientôt des expositions
que de photos est libre d'exposer ce
qu'ils ont envie d'exposer et je pense
que déjà quand quelqu'un a envie
d'exposer je pense que ça a garanti déjà
une certaine qualité artistique
[Musique]
s'autocritique soi-même en fait et voilà
et j'aime pas du tout imposer des thèmes
sculptures peintures ou photographier
les styles se mélangent abstrait ou
figuratif ici l'art se découvre sous
toutes ses variations
[Musique]
le prix saint quentin des collèges et un
lecteur de poésie d'aujourd'hui est
connue les 170 élèves qui composent le
jury ont choisi le recueil de nathalie
d'un an bestiaire tangka le prix sera
remis le mercredi 23 mai à la ferme de
bel ébat s'immerger dans le monde de
l'illustration jeunesse les crayons
n'attendent que vous pour ces rencontres
vagabonde dans les médiathèques de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines et pour faire
le point sur la programmation
valérie payet vous êtes médiathécaires
on va au sein du réseau des médiathèques
de saint-quentin du lit et ce sont des
rencontres sur des illustrations
jeunesse
tout à fait c'est un projet qui est né à
la vagabonde la librairie à versailles
et qui a pour objectif de mettre en
lumière chaque année une maison
d'édition spécialisée en littérature
pour la jeunesse
et cette année ce sont les éditions memo
vous tout à fait pourquoi faire une
collaboration avec une librairie s'est
rapproché les différents publics louis
c'est tout à fait ça et mettre en valeur
pour faire découvrir aux habitants du
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
le ce que c'est que le métier de
d'illustratrice et les maîtres tout à
fait en lumière et justement des
illustratrices il y en a quatre
cette année alors ghislaine herbéra
joncaux nakamura floris centrale élit
noah verdi c'est
les éditions qui vous les ont proposés
c'est vous qui allez vous plonger dans
l'eure en fait c'est un travail
collaboratif en a nous a proposé puis
nous avons choisi et c'est un ce sont
des illustrations qui sont à la fois
très vive et qui intéresse le plus le
jeune public et on imagine aussi que les
parents seront très intéressé par par
ces illustratrice et donc oui elle
elles vont exposer leurs oeuvres et les
enfants sont les rencontrer elles vont
exposer dans les rencontres et ce qu
elles sont actrices toutes ces
rencontres alors le 18 avril ce que ça a
commencé il ya deux semaines à faire à
peu près il y avait un atelier que des
tampons des encres heures c'était le
navire hardy et le 16 mai c'est le
prochain rendez vous c'est florissant
val qui fera du pixel ah oui une
technique de dessin numérique qui voilà
en fait elle elle transpose ses
illustrations en les découpant commune
des pixels et avec des couleurs très
gaies et les enfants sont très preneur
alors il ya des ateliers mais pas
seulement il y à des rencontres il ya
aussi des heures du conte spécial mais
toutes les médiathèques sont nés après
ça profite à fait tout à fait toutes les
médiathèques c'est en particulier la
médiathèque rue rousselot pour l'heure
du conte autour de la maison d'édition
mémo qui ne se contentera pas des quatre
illustratrice présentes mais qui fera un
tour de la maison d'édition alors on
part illustration jeunesse mais
j'imagine que les rendez-vous ne font
pas seulement pour les enfants n'ont
effectivement nous avons aussi organisé
une rencontre pour les professionnels de
l'enfance qui aura lieu à la maison de
quartier
théodore monod à guyancourt et ça sera
au tour du travail de ghislaine herbéra
qui va expliquer comment elle textualité
illustrations et donc tout son travail
d'explication autour du voilà comment en
contextualisant les images
qu'est-ce que l'illustration peut nous
apporter dans la narration de
de l'histoire et il ya aussi donc ses
ateliers ses rencontres mais aussi une
exposition on peut voir aussi les
oeuvres les créations de ces
illustratrice et on peut même me bats en
profiter quand un coup de coeur voilà
quand on aura un coup de coeur on peut
acheter s'ils envie de nous en prendre
merci valérie page et d'être venus en
masse alors pour vagabonder dans
l'illustration jeunesse
direction les médiathèques du réseau et
tout le programme se trouve sur leur
site internet
si je vous dis photographier farine vous
ne voyez pas le lien est pourtant art
nos shoots un photographe de
fontenay-le-fleury propose des portraits
dont la farine est un des éléments clés
camille lambert a joué les modèles et
nicolas kirillovitch a fait les images
la farine vous connaissez bien cet
aliment on utilise beaucoup en
pâtisserie et plus généralement en
cuisine on peut aussi s'en servir en
photographie
arnaud peut nous montrer comment suivez
moi
[Musique]
bonjour arnaud jean camille alors on est
là du coup dans le studio la scène de
crime mention si on peut dire alors
comment ce que vous est venue l'idée de
commencer la faute aux farines en fait
je faisais les photos chez moi des
gouttes d'eau pour faire un petit peu
des photos artistiques et puis un jour
j'ai je me suis dit tiens je vais faire
des photos avec la farine
donc voilà je me suis mis delà de la
farine sur les cheveux j'ai fait un
espèce de mouvement de profil et du coup
ça a donné la première photo farine
voilà c'était moi j'ai des cobayes donc
c'est vraiment on est vraiment
commencement là du coup c'est le premier
portrait vous propose également au
public vise actuellement on va tester ça
aujourd'hui alors tu as fait est-ce que
déjà j'étais à la bonne tenue pour avoir
alors moi je désire avoir le moins de
tissu possible au niveau du haut parce
qu'en fait il faut tout ce qu'on va
s'arrêter au niveau de l'épaule jamais
avoir les polémiques voilà très bientôt
bon bah on va être parti alors du coup
je vais enlever la veste et puis on est
parti ça marche
le but du jeu maintenant c'est de
s'asseoir d'accord une fois qu'on est
assis donc deux profils vous allez
mettre la tête un petit peu en avance je
vous met de la farine sur les cheveux
d'abord et ensuite le mouvement c'est le
traître est simple c'est juste un
mouvement de la tête qui va te bats vers
le coup un mouvement assez sec et rapide
parce que si c'est trop lent être à
paris nous montrait vraiment d'être
l'équivalent qu'il faut c'est qu'ils
rapide aller 1 2 3 4
voilà ça c'est parfait ça
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors la séance est terminée donc on a
fait deux styles de portrait différent
de profils dont je lançais la tête comme
ça et puis de façon je faisais un grand
nom très très convaincu ça disons est ce
que c'est indiqué pour tout type de
personnes même si on n'a jamais fait de
photographier c'est vraiment accessible
à tout le monde c'est accessible à tout
le monde en fait la personne de
portraits s'accepte beaucoup plus
facilement que de s'y opposer par dans
un jardin etc
et puis ça reste des photos artistiques
et je pense que les gens quand ils se
voient ne serait-ce quelques apparitions
dans les cheveux etc
je trouve que voilà leur regard ces
merveilles et il adore la photo comme ça
en tout cas c'est quoi la prochaine
étape là du coup donc là on a fait les
photos brut vous allez leur travail et
aussi après ça sera là tout à fait je
dois travailler sur mon ordinateur et
une fois que je travaillais à ce qu'on
lâche les envoie aux personnes qui sont
intéressées
vous je vous envoie et puis à ce moment
là vous verrez celle que vous voulez
garder pour de bon voilà bon bah voilà
moi j'ai testé en tout cas avec arnaud
donc n'hésitez pas à le contacter arnaud
shops donc il est à fontenay le fleury
est puis sera ravi de vous tirer le
portrait de la farine
c'est moi petite vengeance personnelle
ou poursuivis cette ville culture avec
notre nouvel invité wilfried bosch de la
compagnie les muette bavard bon sens
soit alors vous signé la mise en scène
d'un spectacle qui est à découvrir à
montigny le bretonneux donnant jeudi 3
mai une sorte de brigands et oui une
histoire de brigands pour trois
représentations demain montigny le
bretonneux 20h30 pour les parents et les
enfants donc un tout public et 10h et
14h30 pour des scolaires
oui ces brigands qui dévalise les
voyageurs et qui vont se retrouver dans
une impasse et qui vont changer la
société la culture dans laquelle ils
vivent suite à une rencontre
voilà une question qui va chambouler
et oui c'est celle d'une petite
orpheline qui va effectivement
questionner les brigands sur l' usage de
ce capital qu'ils amassent sans rien en
faire pour le plaisir damas est comme ça
qui va avoir le pouvoir en fait de
donner une nouvelle destination à ce
capital surprise alors ils vont devenir
gentil je pense en fait que l'oeuvre
justement ne nous ressert pas cette
vision manichéenne des choses c'est à
dire qu'une grue heures nous fait
vraiment dépassé cette histoire de bons
et de méchants et questionner justement
ces valeurs qui sont vraiment racine est
dans notre culture et est promu par hbo
coût de produits culturels fil cinéma
pour justement voilà créer un dialogue
avec avec justement cette zone de
rencontre donc il va simplement lui
orienté la question un regard critique
sur les actions qu'est ce qu'ils font
est ce que d'une mauvaise action peut
sortir une bonne action et là dans ce
qu'on voulait c'est l'auteur de l'
ouvrage qui vous a inspiré
pourquoi ce choix retenus en gare d'agen
c'est un grand c'est un hymne aux
sauteurs c'est certainement avec celle
d'acs le plus grand auteur illustrateur
de littérature jeunesse est pas que
littérature jeunesse puisqu'il a fait
aussi des dessins érotiques magnifique
et donc oui là
7 cette autobiographie en fête a été
vraiment récompensé par le prix andersen
pour la totalité de son travail sa
monuments et je ne les ai pas choisis
alors figurez vous que c'est vraiment
marion monnier et déjà dames et l'est
qui sont et directrice artistique de la
compagnie est bavarde qui avait à coeur
de représenter en fait ce livre jeunesse
et je me suis greffé à leur invitation
elles ont vraiment porté tout le début
du projet et tout le début de la
conception du projet je me suis jamais
fait à elle poursuivre la construction
des décors et écrire les paroles des
chansons puisque comme vous le savez il
s'agit d'un acte musical 70 musical tout
à fait on a beaucoup dit déjà je vous
regardez un extrait on continue sur les
trois brigands
[Musique]
mais sur sa mort
et on a vu vous y mêler des marionnettes
et du théâtre d'ombrés et tous types de
marionnettes il ya du style guignols et
des grandes marionnettes
vous vouliez montrer un petit peu tout
cet univers c'était ça a été une
rencontre aussi ses marionnettes là ça a
été une rencontre dans le fond on fait
d'un antiquaire en italie à parme qui
est une région qui a une grande
tradition de marionnettes ces deux
marionnettes qui ont plus de cent ans et
qu'on a fait restaurer pour l'occasion
donc c'est vraiment j'irai pas des
pièces de musée parce que bon les
marionnettes de ce type là en italie en
a beaucoup et puis parmi un magnifique
musée de la marionnette donc mais on les
a fait restaurer je te dire que à la
création du spectacle
ça a été une émotion extraordinaire pour
moi d'être simplement dans la salle et
de connaître en fait le le parcours de
ces deux scénarios net lac qui
retrouvent leur destination d'acteurs et
une grande marionnette donc fabriqué par
francesco attesti donc est vraiment une
instructrice de marianne est remarquable
et directrice de compagnies aussi
extraordinaire qui nous a qui nous a
fabriqué la grande marionnette de
tiffany voilà donc on a les deux écoles
on a une jeune marionnettes une nouvelle
née je dirais et puis des marionnettes
traditionnelles
le metteur en scène avait choisi d'être
très fidèle au texte original on
retrouve carrément les chapeaux ces
trois brigands oui c'était aussi une
identification peut-être pour les abus
qu'ils ont lu enfants oui peut-être le
même je dirais que le souci qu'on a eu
un tout ça a été vraiment de ne pas
toucher un mot texte parce qu'il s'agit
vraiment d'un tel monument que
voilà il fallait vraiment vraiment lui
donner lui laisser toute son intégrité
pour aussi donner toute la dimension du
compte à ce spectacle là et intégrée
tout l'élément musicale donc qui a été
une musique composée par gustavo
beytelmann qui est vraiment un des grand
compositeur argentin actuel laissait la
place justement à la musique aux paroles
des chansons voilà d'infiltrer un petit
peu plus sur la ce climat nocturne ce
climat un petit peu inquiétant mais
voilà donc on sait par rapport par
rapport au travail voilà on sait on sait
tous se retrouver autour de autour de
ces idées là de cette idée là merci
alors les trois brigands c'est à
découvrir le jeudi 3 mai à 20 heures à
la salle jacques-brel de montigny le
bretonneux et on passe maintenant à
notre page cinéma
[Musique]
le coup de coeur cinéma de la semaine
fait celui de bertrand pin et on se rend
aux yeux d'elsa de saint cyr l'école
oui donc le coup de coeur du cinéma les
yeux d'elsa
cette semaine c'est le film l'île aux
chiens de wes anderson le retour de wes
anderson a au cinéma d'animation après
avoir fait fantastique mr fox en 2009
il est connu ce monsieur il nous a fait
la famille tenembaum d'un à bord du
darjeeling limited
il avait fait aussi plus récemment
ce grand succès grande budapest hôtels
des films toujours un peu étrange avec
toujours des castings de superstar des
acteurs américains très pointu qui sont
utilisés pour leur côté burlesque leur
capacité de comédie et c'est là après
avoir fait
incarnez un renard par george clooney il
va faire incarné par edward norton bill
murray et puis tout un tas d'autres gens
qu'on voit ici il va faire incarner des
chiens à ces gens là
il a également dirigé le casting
française qui est intéressant puisque la
version originale la version française
du coup on était dirigé par le même
réalisateur
en tout cas cette intrigue que nous vous
recommandons fortement qui est vraiment
une sorte de petit bijou travailler en
animation à la main pas du tout par
ordinateur et qui raconte une histoire
dans un japon futuriste avec des chiens
qui parlent des humains qui parle aussi
des chiens qui ont des pensées
philosophiques sur le monde et sur
l'avenir de l'humanité
en tout cas voilà un vrai film
particulier à découvrir au cinéma les
yeux d'elsa cette semaine et la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
les célèbres contes et poèmes de jean de
la fontaine en concert l'académicien
erik orsenna
vous en êtes dans le pays vrai du poète
début de l'évènement à 17 heures et
l'entrée est gratuite mais sur
réservation à la ferme de bel ébat c'est
un voyage musical dans le temps qui vous
attend la compagnie du loup ange marie
musique ancienne aux arts visuels
numériques sauvage rondo pour quatre
mains ses pieds est un théâtre musical
et corporel à découvrir le samedi 5 mai
il signe d'un z qui veut dire un zorro
le célèbre vengeur masqué vie de
nouvelles aventures à plaisir les
cavalcades du héros sont à vivre au
théâtre espace coluche ce samedi
extraits sorosoro exactement mon père
disait toujours c'est une année la force
et le courage du lion utilise la ruse
dur las vegas torrio craignez la justice
de zorro c'est la fin de ce site une
culture merci de nous avoir suivi on se
retrouve mercredi prochain
[Musique]